donc on vous a fait une petite liste et
à vous de retrouver bien évidemment euh
à qui correspond cette galère alors j'ai
eu des relations intimes dans le train
alors ça n'a rien avec ce que j'ai dit
bien évidemment
une galère que ce ça te rappelle dans un
train alors j'ai eu des relations
intimes en train alors
non mais pourquoi parce que là
ça va pas ou quoi non moi je pense à
Bertrand
et bien oui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
les gens dans mes profondément et comme
on était que quatre ouais on sait voilà
réservé toute la première
du chapeau voilà
il était assis sur sa trousse il se
trouve que cette personne était une
personne politique
de Tahiti ouais absolument mais de
Tahiti j'en ai déjà beaucoup trop dit
voilà
c'est mon avion a failli se cracher la
semaine dernière alors à mon avis on ne
sait pas le tien bien évidemment
normal
ça bouge trop un avion de ligne oui un
avion logique quoi logique
parfois un avion c'est quelque chose de
simple
quand je pense que je disais hier
qu'elle faisait semblant d'être cru
alors oui racontez-moi
on a décollé
il était bizarre l'avion était vraiment
bizarre et puis peut-être 30 minutes
avant d'arriver là on voit les hôtesses
en panique les machins ça bouge partout
etc et ils ont mis l'avion en face
d'alerte je sais pas ce que c'était et
oui
et tu avais les hôtesses au bout et les
hôtesses et moi je commence à paniquer
on va atterrir machin etc attachez-vous
ne vous soyez pas surpris les pompiers
nous attendent à l'arrivée qu'est-ce que
c'est ça il y avait une ancienne hôtesse
de vent et vous savez que les hôtesses
les anciennes d'Air France pardon
easyJet et et British Airways
ils sont réquisitionnés en cas de phase
d'alerte donc là la fille qui était
devant qui me calmait elle s'est levée
alors là ça va encore plus mille
angoisses et d'un coup on a tous paniqué
et là il y a l'hôtesse au fond qui fait
ah c'est bon
une hystérique et là on s'est mis en
panique totale bref ah mais quoi ça vous
saoule ce que je dis
anecdote
elle se termine quand votre histoire
encore voilà
bien sûr alors j'ai alors GP sur le test
de l'air sur un pari rio de la série
non moi c'était la même personne j'ai
fait un Tahiti Paris
[Rires]
c'est vrai que Tahiti papa pète pareil
on a le temps ça c'est 24 ans on a le
temps de en tout cas c'est qui
je travaille je travaille je voyage
beaucoup ah oui je sais bien sûr il y a
quand même 30 ans
j'ai fait Madrid
et je voyage
et je vois et je vois et crois-moi je
voyage beaucoup tu le sais et
j'ai mon ami qui était à Rio je dois
rejoindre amis
rejoins-moi et j'étais avec son frère et
son frère dormait à côté de moi bah
alors lui avec le masque et tout et
ronfler et tout
pas peur du tout et moi dans l'avion je
tourne je tourne et je tournais et à ça
à un moment donné dans la nuit tu vois
dans tu peux aller au bar il y a
l'hôtesse de l'air avant oui
tu peux boire avec elle et tout et j'ai
discuté avec elle elle m'a vu angoissée
elle m'a fait un petit massage
et après je raconte plus ah d'accord
donc après ah oui maintenant
je crois non je crois vas-y possible
en fait quand on fait beaucoup de la
navette moi je vais travailler à Los
Angeles et en fait on finit par
connaître les équipages donc forcément
justifier encore des cochonneries alors
pas du tout alors dans le triple 7 je
vous raconte et en fait une cabine qui
est au-dessus bah oui qui sert aux
hôtesses et voilà et donc on peut monter
là et on est et on est et on est allongé
et on est on est très bien très très
bien
et ensuite j'ai très bien dormi bah
j'imagine
alors les amis alors je me suis je me
suis fait sortir d'un train par la
police ferroviaire alors ça c'est ça
c'est
merveilleuse c'est ça ouais c'est sûr en
fait j'allais en boîte barneville-cartes
voilà
Barneville-Carteret dans le Nord euh
voilà et j'avais mes plafonds de cartes
étaient full et donc du coup je pouvais
pas retirer je pouvais pas payer et donc
du coup je vais voir le chef de bord et
je lui dis est-ce que je peux monter
dans le train parce que en fait voilà
est-ce que j'ai pas de billets est-ce
que vous m'autorisez il m'a dit non et
donc je dis mais je suis prêt à payer
l'amende voilà faut vraiment absolument
que j'y aille parce que j'ai j'ai pas le
temps et donc du coup il me dit non je
rentre quand même et je m'installe et le
mec qui me dit de toute façon le train
ne partira pas tant que vous serez pas
sorti bravo donc et donc je lui dis bah
franchement je vous ai dit que je suis
prêt à payer l'amende et là il appelle
la police ferroviaire et là les mecs ils
arrivent ils me descendent et voilà
c'était et du coup